[Musique]
treize 180 la guerre de cent ans endure
depuis 43 ans
s'amorce alors une période d'accalmie
deux jeunes rois ont le pouvoir met sous
tutelle à cette fragilité politique
s'ajoute une profonde crise sociale et
morale
la fin du 14ème siècle voit toute
l'europe occidentale plongés dans un
chaos qui n'est que transition d'un
monde à un autre le monde médiéval cède
la place au monde moderne sans pour
autant totalement disparaître
l'imaginaire du moyen-âge laissera en
héritage une référence immortel qui
grâce à sa foi assurera cette transition
jeanne la pucelle d'orléans jeanne d'arc
elle ressemblait à un danger et on était
un peut-être parce que il ya quelque
chose d'extraordinaire devoir de
surnaturel a constaté que cette petite
jeune fille qui est née de deux paysans
de jacques d'arc à domrémy et d'isabelle
rom et sa maman qui ne savaient
quasiment pas lire pas écrire va réussir
à bouleverser l'histoire du monde
ce deuxième cycle de la guerre de cent
ans s'articule comme le premier des
conquête anglaise suivie d'un retour en
force de la monarchie française
construire le royaume de france ce n'est
pas évident et il y a tout le temps ça
durera presque aussi longtemps que la
que la royauté ou la monarchie il y aura
toujours une double menace contre le
pouvoir royal centrale la menace
extérieure
et puis la menace intérieure avec des
révoltes de grand seigneur
une différence de taille cependant cette
fois ce retour permet à la situation de
définitivement se stabiliser et à chaque
nation de s'accorder avec un territoire
qui correspond quasiment à celui dans
lequel elles vivent encore aujourd'hui
[Musique]
en france le règne de charles ciss prend
une tournure inattendue à partir de 13
100 92 alors que le cortège royal fait
route vers la bretagne la lance d'un
homme de garde vient heurter le casque
d'un autre soldat
cette maladresse agit comme un stimulus
pour charles e6 est déclenché sa
première crise de paranoïa il s'attaque
sans raison apparente aux membres du
cortège et notamment à son frère louis
le duc d'orléans
selon certaines sources il y aurait eu
des morts
que faire quand votre roi qui a été
sacrée vous attaquent retrouvant ses
esprits il est incapable d'expliquer son
comportement
une autre fois dans une soirée chez le
duc d'orléans est bien dans une soirée
déguisée les arbres n fun était enduit
détour
enfin bref les crises de folie vont se
répétaient les unes les autres
mais charles vii a été fabriqué dieu
merci un an avant les premières crises
folie si je puis dire de charles 6
pendant encore trente ans la france aura
un roi fou des princes de sang se
disputent alors le pouvoir d'un côté son
unique frère louis d'orléans
de l'autre son oncle paternel le duc de
bourgogne philippe ii le hardi à la tête
d'un territoire en pleine expansion sans
faire la guerre par mariage vient
s'ajouter la flandre un duché déjà
puissant en angleterre le pacifisme de
richard ii n'est pas au goût de tout le
monde
la guerre est populaire elle se déroule
en france et pour les grands barons
anglais ce ne peut être qu'une source de
profit en plus richard accumule les
maladresses en politique intérieure il
ne comprend pas qu'il ne peut toucher ni
aux libertés des villes né à celle du
parlement
son cousin henri de lancastre fini par
obtenir le soutien nécessaire à
l'usurpation du trône d'angleterre
il devient henri iv en 13 199 élimine
définitivement le fils du prince noir en
14 cents une nouvelle page se tourne en
angleterre elle débute par une guerre
civile que la france 2 peut exploiter
trop occupé à se préparer elle mène à
sombrer dans une crise similaire
le mouvement de révolte qui parcourt
l'angleterre est un mouvement qui
rappelle la jacquerie en france entre
c'est un mouvement aux racines multiples
à la fois économiques fiscales politique
qui marque une véritable crise au tout
début du règne du roi d'angleterre à
partir de 14 104 avec l'arrivée de jean
sans peur à la tête du duché de
bourgogne la lune influence avec louis
d'orléans tourne à l'affrontement à mort
après avoir été écarté du conseil royal
jean sans peur utilise la réputation
sulfureuse de louis d'orléans afin de
faire basculer définitivement l'opinion
publique en sa faveur
bon ou mauvais gestionnaires louis est
seul responsable de la crise que
traverse le royaume a man ou non de la
reine
louis est considéré comme tel
c'est en prenant congé d'elle peu avant
minuit le 23 novembre 14 107 que louis
est victime d'un guet-apens alors qu'il
traverse paris avec une escorte réduite
dit cet homme la grèce à l'armé blanche
de lui laissant aucune chance
jean sans peur est immédiatement
soupçonné mais se fait oublier pendant
un temps un temps seulement le peuple ne
regrette pas louis et le duc de
bourgogne s'est constitué un solide
réseau un an après le meurtre de louis
son assassin peut réintégrer le conseil
royal
il va jusqu'à justifier le crime d'un
tyran et promet des changements qui vont
asseoir sa popularité à paris le nouveau
duc d'orléans n'a pas les épaules pour
s'opposer c'est son beau père bernard
d'armagnac qui devient le chef de file
d'une opposition qui contrôle encore la
moitié du royaume paris va devenir le
théâtre d'une tragédie sanglante ou un
roi fou continue d'incarner le pouvoir
charles vii
on le sait le 11e enfants de 10 à bo de
bavière et du roi folle charles ciss et
c'est un garçon qui va attendre très
longtemps que son père qui n'est plus en
état de renier gard charles si ce n'est
plus en état de renier rendre son âme à
dieu avant de pouvoir lui même prendre
le pouvoir et pendant ce temps là et
bien c'est isabeau de bavière qui assure
une manière de régence
mais elle assure une régence avec deux
factions politiques extrêmement
importantes qui sont les bourguignons le
parti de bourguignon est le parti
armagnac
entre armagnacs et bourguignons le
rapport de forces est équilibrée afin de
le faire basculer la tentation est
grande de demander une intervention
anglaise avec la flandre sous sa
responsabilité jean sans peur de bonnes
raisons de s'entendre avec l'angleterre
qui permet grâce à sa laine d'entretenir
le dynamisme des villes qui vivent du
textile chants seront peur très
rapidement et surtout à la demande du
jabot de bavière va prendre le parti
anglais véritablement le parti anglais
surtout que le quand la reine va
entraîner trois offrir le royaume de
france au roi d'angleterre et jean sans
peur évidemment se voit déjà très bien
placé dans le temps le gouvernement
le duché de bourgogne devient un
troisième élément dans cette tragédie de
100 ans
un élément perturbateur le 6 janvier 14
112 dans un petit village de lorraine du
nom de domrémy jacques d'arc paysans
aisés aurait pu inscrire dans un
registre paroissial qui n'existait pas
encore sa fille jane un élément
équilibrant qui allait s'inscrire
elle-même dans le marbre de l'histoire
le 20 mars 14 113 henry 4 meur henry 5 à
25 ans et a soif de justice une justice
qu'ils estiment être celle de dieu il
s'appuie sur le seul traité signé depuis
le début du conflit
celui de calais en 13 160 il exige la
restitution des territoires qui depuis
ont été très heureusement à l'excès par
la france
lui le fils de l'usurpateur se
considèrent l héritier des plantagenêts
de guillaume le conquérant
en ce sens il est hors de question pour
henry 5 de faire une croix sur le duché
de normandie
au cours des négociations qu'il entame
avec l'entourage de charles ciss compte
tenu de la situation en france cette
soif est loin d'être surréaliste
notamment quand une partie du réseau
constitué par jean sans peur dans la
capitale devient hors de contrôle en
avril 14 113 la corporation des bouchers
fidéliser à l'aide du vin de bourgogne
met la pression sur les états généraux
réunis afin de trancher entre armagnacs
et bourguignons et c'est comme enivrée
que c'est bush y font régner la terreur
dans paris les rues deviennent des
abattoirs armagnac les parisiens folle
et réclame un retour à l'ordre
simon le coutelier ce garçon simon le
coutelier qu'on surnomme sur caboche et
comment dirais-je le grand patron de la
confrérie des bouchers et ces gens là
vêtus de leurs robes de boucher le robe
blanche et bien vont essayer de le
prendre le pouvoir tout simplement
et ils vont même s'emparer en 14 113
c'est-à-dire bien avant 1789 ils vont
s'emparer de la bastille les cabochons
les bouchers et ils vont ce pur pour eux
pour se procurer des armes pour faire le
coup de force dans paris les armagnacs
assoiffé de vengeance deviennent à leur
tour boucher en égorgeant du bourguignon
après ses sommets atteints dans la
violence les tensions persistent c'est
dans ce contexte qu'en doute 14 115 ans
les 5 débarque avec douze mille hommes
dans l'embouchure de la seine jean sans
peur le duc de bourgogne n'envoie pas de
troupes au sol des armagnacs font se
dresser sur la route de cette nouvelle
chevauchée anglaise à l'intérieur du
royaume de france en septembre henry 5
prend harfleur qui alimente la seine et
paris
mais même avec l'aide de dieu
mieux valait attendre le printemps pour
poursuivre l'offensive
henry décide de l'attendre à calais est
en chemin de semer la panique
l'armée que les armagnacs ont rassemblé
lui coupe la route
la rencontre a lieu à zain cour le 25
octobre 14 115
les français sont au moins deux fois
plus nombreux malgré la défection
bourguignonne mais la cohésion et du
côté anglais à la fin du xvième siècle
shakespeare mais ses mots dans la bouche
dans glee 5
car quiconque aujourd'hui verse son sens
avec moi ce sera mon frère si humble
qu'il soit ce jour anoblir à sa
condition
sur le plateau d'un cours
la pluie tombe abondamment depuis la
veille et tandis que les français ont
dormi en tenue de combat les anglais ont
monté leur campement serein connaissant
la répugnance de la chevalerie française
a chargé sur terre un bout c'est henry 5
qui donnent l'assaut à 11 heures du
matin
c'est archi perdre moins de mobilité que
des hommes d'armes à cheval se
protégeant derrière un pieu qu'ils
plantent devant eux ils avancent
inexorablement sur les flancs des lignes
françaises
les anglais n'ont pas comme nos deux
lourds chevaux de lourdes armures qui en
pèse les montures les anglais
essentiellement maintenant de
l'infanterie des fantassins armée de
dark rapide nerveux léger si bien que
quand toute la cavalerie française va
venir se confronter aux archers et bien
elle va être complètement transpercée
par les traits par les flèches la
cavalerie anglaise comme à crécy en
13146 comme à poitiers en 13,156 achève
la besogne à l'épée c'est l'hécatombe
côté français dix fois plus de pertes
pour les historiens 100 fois plus pour
shakespeare
quel que soit le chiffre dieu et du côté
d'henry 5 qui retourne en angleterre
préparer les négociations avec les
représentants du pouvoir français
la cavalerie à partir de la bataille
d'azincourt a fini quasiment d'exister
dans les grandes batailles de l'histoire
[Musique]
un pacte de non-agression et consentie
entre henri jean mais à sens unique
dix mille anglais débarque à nouveau en
août 14 117
mais ce n'est plus une chevauchée c'est
la conquête de la normandie
la progression est méthodique jusqu'au
siège de roi la ville résiste mais paris
embourbé dans la guerre civile ne réagit
pas
en juin 14 78 le chef des armagnacs est
éliminé par de nouveaux bouchers avec
les anglais alliés aux bourguignons la
maison d orléans soutenu par les
armagnacs se regroupent autour de
l'héritier du trône de france
un dauphin de 16 ans portant le même
prénom que son père charles
tandis que ce dernier reste un pantin
entre les mains de jean sans peur
le dauphin fui la capitale le parti les
bourguignons et le plus puissant
manifestement dans le conseil de régence
est est ce parti est favorable aux
anglais
et quand les anglais vont naturellement
arrivé et bien paris ne sera
pratiquement plus aux mains du fils du
roi de france du dauphin charles sait
bien que il va le voir le baril est aux
mains des bourguignons et des anglais
réunit et lui va devoir quitter paris
piteusement et venir se réfugier où ça
et bien à bourges puisque on l'appellera
le petit roi de bourges à partir de ce
moment là rouen fini par capituler ou
début de l'hiver en 14 119
commence alors une implantation anglaise
durable en normandie connecter la grande
bretagne par la manche devant les
prétentions grandissante d'henri 5 jean
sans peur tente de trouver un accord
avec le dauphin qu'ils rencontrent à
plusieurs reprises chaque rencontre
s'effectue dans une atmosphère
extrêmement tendue jusqu'à la dernière
de 10 septembre à 14 919 sur le pont de
montereau l'entretien dégénère s'ensuit
une mêlée dans laquelle jean sans peur
trouvent la mort guette apens prémédité
ou négociations diplomatiques qui tourne
mal
toujours est il que les relations entre
bourgogne et de gouvernement qui se
forme autour du dauphin sont
définitivement rompu
[Musique]
à la mort de jean sans peur
le fils de jean sans peur leduc le
nouveau duc de bourgogne philippe lebon
s'allie au roi d'angleterre henry 5
c'est le début de l'alliance franco
bourguignonne qui va livrer la france le
royaume de france à l'angleterre
d'ailleurs françois 1er nous raconte que
quelques années plus tard en voyage à
dijon en bourgogne un moine lui montra
le crâne de jean sans peur avec le trou
du cul l'épée qu'il avait eue dans le
kram et lemoine dire à françois 1er
voyez vous c'est par ce trou sire que
les anglais sont rentrés dans le royaume
de france
le fils de jean sans peur philippe lebon
va rechercher la paix avec l'angleterre
à n'importe quel prix henry 5 utilise à
merveille la situation transformant
l'événement politique en tragédie le
successeur de charles ciss a perdu son
droit a régné au nom de dieu
s'appuyant sur une tradition antique
henry 5 se fait adopter par charles ciss
en épousant sa fille tout en respectant
le roi fou et l'imposent l'idée d'une
double monarchie
deux royaumes distincts mais un seul roi
à partir de la mort de charles ciss qui
n'a plus d'héritier digne de ce nom
sinon son nouveau gendre tout cela est
actée par le traité de trois ans 14 120
est scellé par le mariage d'henri 5 avec
catherine de france isabeau de bavière
fait appel directement aux anglais armes
et un aux troupes anglaises va
promulguer avec charles ciss le foll le
traité de trois ans 14 120 qui va
déshérités son fils elle déshérite
charles vii pour placer sur le trône le
roi d'angleterre reste dauphin toute la
partie sud de la france quatre cent
trente trois ans de construction pas
sciemment orchestré par le capétiens
sont brutalement remise en cause c'est
tout aussi brutalement qu'une hémorragie
intestinale emporte henry 5
deux ans plus tard c'est la première
étape afin d'espérer un changement dans
le rapport de force
[Musique]
à 35 ans il laisse un fils éponyme d'à
peine 2 ans fils de catherine est censé
recevoir à sa majorité les deux
couronnes le régions du royaume de
france devient le duc de bedford
au grand dam de philippe lebon au nord
le royaume de france est dominé par
l'alliance anglo bourguignonne avec
d'une part le régent duc de bedford
régent du royaume de france au nom de
son neveu en russie ce qui est un tout
jeune enfant et d'autre part le duc de
bourgogne philippe lebon le fils de jean
sans peur qui a fait alliance avec les
anglais ou après le meurtre de son père
à montereau le sud du royaume continue
en revanche à obéir à charles vii
l'ancien dauphin charles c'est ce qu'on
appelle le royaume de bourges
parce qu'il a sa capitale à bourges et à
poitiers
c'est la même année que meurent charles
ciss le dauphin devient charles vii mais
uniquement pour ses partisans
et lors d'une cérémonie qui n'est pas un
sacre pour cela il faut aller à reims et
régner à paris jeanne dix ans
aucun français digne de ce nom ne peut
adhérer au traité de troyes malgré
l'espoir d'une paix durable pour le plus
grand bien de toute la chrétienté
charles vii organise une armée avait des
fidèles s'appuie sur les alliances
écossaise castillane et lombarde pour
poursuivre la lutte contre les anglais
et la guerre civile contre les
bourguignons
c'est en pays lorrain sous domination
bourguignonne mais à l'intérieur d'une
enclave fidèle aux dauphins la
châtellenie de vaucouleurs que se situe
dont ray mais le petit village n'est pas
épargnée par les violences au cours de
l'été 14 125 dont le jardin de la maison
familiale pour la première fois jeanne
entend une voix qui lui parle de la
misère dans laquelle se trouve le
royaume elle a 13 ans
[Musique]
que ce soit du côté du dauphin du côté
anglo bourguignon les deux camps ont
besoin de souffler aucune opération
d'envergure n'est lancé jusqu'en 428 le
duc de bedford décide de passer la loire
la cible orléans
ce n'est plus une voix qui pousse jeanne
à agir mais des voix
saint michel dont le mot en normandie
résiste si bien aux assauts anglais
sainte-catherine comme la soeur de
jeanne qui vient de mourir et sainte
marguerite
la patronne des femmes en couche jeanne
a une mission confiée par dieu
elle en parle à son entourage on sait
que la petite jeanne sur le coup de 13
14 15 ans à des voix un chacun le sait
les voies de saint michel sainte
catherine sainte-marguerite et des voix
qu'il lui dise voilà on a choisi toi
parce qu'il faut que tu fasses quelque
chose il faut que tu ailles voir le roi
de france faut que tu lui dises que il
doit être vraiment roi de france et
c'est toi qui vas y aller en septembre
14 128 les anglais avec l'aide d'un
contingent envoyé par philippe lebon
commence le siège d'orléans
il élève des bastides autour de la ville
pour tenter de couper tous les accès
mais trop peu nombreux ils laissent
quelques brèches dans leur dispositif
fils illégitime de louis d'orléans
dunois lebastard d'orléans assure le
ravitaillement pendant combien de temps
les orléanais ne font-ils pas bientôt
être réduits à manger des rats comme
ceux de rouen 10 ans plus tôt et finir
par céder
voilà un premier défi pour qui fait agir
quand débute l'année 14 129 jane vient
d'avoir 17 ans et charles vii est loin
d'imaginer qu'il sera sacré avant la fin
de l'été mais le 12 février
accompagné par son oncle jeanne réussit
à convaincre le seigneur de vos couleurs
elle s'en va d'abord à tout à côté à
vaucouleurs voir le capitaine de la
place richard de broderie cours et elle
lui dit il faut que j'aille voir le roi
de france que qui vit je crois
actuellement à chinon wolof évidemment
mettez nous mettons nous à la place du
capitaine qui éclate de rire en voyant
cette petite gamine mal fagotée lui
parler d'eux des choses de la royauté du
royaume de france et un 1 6 et insistent
et c'est ça la puissance de jeanne d'arc
c'est qu'elle a une force de persuasion
un pouvoir de conviction phénoménal
c'est bien que au bout de trois
rencontres
monsieur baudricourt lui dit écoutez il
ya quelque chose qui m'échappe mais ça
me dépasse c'est plus fort que moi et il
va lui donner un petit équipage et va
lui dire les va va et advienne que
pourra
en ces temps troublés l'espoir repose
sur l'avenir et dans cette société
encore médiévale c'est dieu qui fait
l'avenir
il utilise parfois l'intercession
d'hommes ou de femmes qui par leurs
prophéties apporte la foi en des jours
meilleurs
soulage les âmes et regonfle les corps
de courage la virginité est la
conviction de jeunes sont ses principaux
arguments
c'est elle qui lèvera le siège d'orléans
le seigneur de vaucouleurs lui remettent
une lettre d'introduction et une escorte
pour aller jusqu'à chine ont trouvé
charles vii que jeanne continue à
appeler le dauphin
tant qu'il n'est pas sacré pour
chevaucher en pays bourguignon jeanne
prend des amis d'hom son arrivée à
chinon est annoncée illettrée elle dicte
une missive adressée aux dauphins
le 23 février jeanne entre dans china
charles et son conseil se décide à la
recevoir
cette entrevue de chinon entre jeanne
d'arc et charles vii est considéré par
beaucoup d'historiens comme un tournant
dans la guerre de cent ans puisque
jeanne d'arc est un personnage
éminemment charismatique elle a réussi à
convaincre le futur roi de france de lui
confier un rôle militaire et
d'accompagner les armées du roi de
france notamment pour délivrer la ville
d'orléans et les teams immédiatement
soumise à un test celui qu'on lui
présente n'est pas le dauphin ces
voix-là guide jusqu'à lui
à moins que lui même poussé par la
curiosité ne se soit rallié la force de
conviction de la pucelle fait le reste
en présence du conseil et au cours d'un
entretien privé avec charles la scène ne
s'est pas passé tout à fait comme ça en
fait il ya eu deux entrevues et les
historiens ont scindé ses deux entrevues
en une entrevue mythique et légendaire
lors de la première entrevue le dauphin
charles a reçu jeanne d'arc en petit
comité et probablement pas dans la
grande salle de la forteresse charles
vii pensait qu'il n'était pas le fils de
son père charles ciss parce que il a
boat bavière la maman c'est un peu une
traînée qui avait été à droite et de
gauche de droite et de gauche
si bien que charles vii il disait toute
manière je ne suis pas le fils mon
perles
donc je ne peux pas hérité le royaume de
france et elle lui dit ici elle ne
convainc gagli vous êtes charles vii le
roi de france le fils de charles ciss le
dauphin charles qui n'a pas été
complètement convaincu par la prestation
de jeanne d'arc l'a envoyé à poitiers là
où résidaient ses conseillers ses
théologiens pour que jeanne d'arc soient
interrogés et que sa bonne foi soit
vérifié le des théologiens qui vont lui
poser des questions et surtout un examen
de corps parce qu'il faut savoir si il
s'agit vraiment d'une femme et il suffit
s'agit de savoir aussi si si elle est
plus elle est en effet après l'examen et
bien je la petite jeanne s'avère être
une pucelle et on sait que dans
l'histoire elle restera comme la pucelle
d'orléans bien sûr
un autre test l'attend cependant à
poitiers un examen devant des
théologiens qui va durer trois semaines
les inspirations de jeanne doivent être
conformes aux dogmes de l'église
la preuve idéal serait un signe sous la
forme d'un miracle jeanne ne peut leur
en fournir ici à poitiers mais si on
l'envoie à orléans
elle promet qu'il y en aura malgré les
signes d'impatience que jeanne n'essaie
pas de cachet puisqu'elle se doit d'agir
malgré le fait qu'elle porte des habits
d'homme le conseil de sages de la juge
il folle ni corrompus par le diable et
compte tenu de la situation tragique
dans laquelle se trouve le royaume
ce conseil autorise le dauphin accéder à
ces requêtes
une escorte armée pour l'amener à
orléans à cette mise à l'épreuve à
poitiers jeanne d'arc revient à la
forteresse le 27 mars 1429 et comme elle
a apporté aux conseillers du roi
toutes les réponses qu'ils attendaient a
lieu à ce moment-là la forteresse de
chillon la seconde entrevue probablement
dans la grande salle de la forteresse au
cours de laquelle le futur roi présente
jeanne d'arc à la cour et l'investît
officiellement de ses missions et
notamment des livres et le royaume de
france
on commence à parler de jeanne et de 22
mars elle dicte une lettre destinée aux
anglais leur sommant de quitter le
royaume de france
ils vont te aussi commencé à parler de
plus en plus de la pucelle
en effet une opération de communication
à grande échelle est lancée à travers le
royaume et au delà jeanne devient une
bergère afin de mieux coller à
l'imagerie biblique on adjointe au
dossier de propagande des prophéties qui
évoque une vierge en armes et la
libération du pays ont fait le récit du
parcours de chan de vaucouleurs à
poitiers en passant par chinon en y
ajoutant quelques épisodes merveilleux
ont conclu avec la lettre de janot
anglais et qu'après leur réponse
insultante jeanne se dirige vers orléans
avec un étendard blanc faut toujours
rappeler quand on parle de van darc que
ce qu'ils avaient de curieux c'est que
la cour de charles vii était plutôt
dépravés
plutôt mauvaise chrétienne d'hier et
aujourd'hui et
le clan de de la vertu c'était plutôt le
clan adverse et ses salles
la singularité de de jeanne d'arc c'est
qu'elle apporte une image de pureté au
clan à au camp le plus pour le moins
vertueux en apparence jeune suit une
préparation militaire sommaire alors
qu'elle excelle à cheval les rudiments
qu'elle apprend sur l'utilisation des
armes ne lui permettent pas de rivaliser
avec les professionnels de la guerre
elle reçoit une armure une épée et un
étendard dont elle choisit la scène des
images de la vierge et du christ lors du
jugement dernier bénissant des fleurs de
lys porté par les deux archange avec
l'inscription jésus maria orléans des
sons matar l'attend impatiemment famars
désespéré la ville a envoyé une
ambassade à philippe lebon orléans est
prête à se soumettre aux ducs de
bourgogne plutôt qu'aux anglais il faut
à philippe l'autorisation du duc de
bedford qui se moque des prétentions de
son allié le 17 avril le contingent
bourguignon quittent le siège laissant
les effectifs anglais à leur blocus de
moins en moins étanche
côté français des renforts sont
constitués à blois
parmi toutes ces bonnes nouvelles celles
qui re donne le plus de baume au coeur
des orléanais et que parmi ces renforts
se trouve chan
on a entendu parler d'elle et son
charisme va faire de cette armée de
secours une machine de guerre ou les
blasphèmes sont interdits il faut savoir
qu'on dispose que d'une seule image de
jeune d'arc exécuté de son vivant et
c'est un petit croquis exécuté par un
greffier du parlement de paris
on n'a pas d'autres images de jeanne
d'arc de son vivant ce détail fait que
l'image de jeanne d'arc ont l'image
qu'on nous donne de jeanne d'arc a varié
au cours des siècles
on a par exemple aux xviie et au xviiie
siècle l'image d'une héroïne très
féminine presque une courtisane habillés
avec des robes avec des cheveux longs et
bouclés et qui porte souvent un élégant
chapeau à plumes qui est en fait son
panache le symbole de la victoire à
l'époque ce n'est qu' à la fin du 19e
siècle que jeanne d'arc va acquérir une
image un petit peu plus militaire et
c'est sans doute lié au conflit et
notamment à celui de 1870 où elle est
davantage représentés en armure intégral
et avec des cheveux pour quand le
batardeau relayant sorte une nouvelle
fois de sa ville pour aller à la
rencontre de jeanne le 29 avril elle est
en colère
un patient de traverser la loire est de
se rendre dans la ville assiégée
la ville est prise d'assaut les anglais
ont décidé de faire une ceinture une
ceinture hermétique autour d'orléans
pour éviter que l'on puisse en sortir et
qu'on puisse rentrer mais jeanne d'arc
réussit donc à apporter des vivres et va
franchir toutes ces petites bastille que
les anglais avaient placé autour de la
ville jeanne est accueilli par une foule
en liesse
pourtant il ne décolère pas tenue à
l'écart de la stratégie elle attend le 4
mai avant de livrer son premier combat
on attaque une des bastides du
dispositif anglais sont à prévenir
tandis que l'offensive sans jeanne
échoue une contre attaque avec elle
finit par le démantèlement de la
fortification anglaise alors que rien ne
pouvait penser de laisser à penser
qu'elle était un grand stratège elle
veut nuire c'est là qu'il faut attaquer
c'est là qu'il faut c'est la tour c les
tournelles qu'il faut prendre etc etc
parce que dieu me l'a dit et en effet
tous accompli comme dieu le lui a dit
jeanne n'avait jamais été confronté à
autant de souffrance en même temps mais
les bastilles vont maintenant tomber
comme des dominos le 6 mai une seconde
cède comme la première à partir de
l'arrivée de jame les anglais se replie
dans la bastille maîtresse du dispositif
l'état major français choisi d'attendre
de nouveaux renforts avant de lever
totalement le siège sous l'impulsion de
jeanne le 7 mai l'assaut est tout de
même donné j'en ai blessé d'un trait
d'arbalète à l'épaule sainte catherine
lara sur l'armée de jeanne se décourage
elle propose à ses soldats de se
restaurer pendant qu'elle prix puis
ordonne de reprendre l'assaut une
colombe passe dans le ciel d'orléans et
la tour cède le lendemain dimanche lui
mais des survivants anglais quittent les
dernières bastille et laissent derrière
eux orléans libre
la première mission de jeannette
accompli c'est aussi le signe que tout
le monde attendait la levée du siège
n'est pourtant pas un miracle
elle s'explique d'un point de vue de la
stratégie militaire d'effectifs déjà
réduit les anglais se sont éparpillés à
l'intérieur d'un dispositif incomplet il
a suffi d'un peu de folie pour réveiller
des forces vives seulement dormi les
succès militaires qu'on attribue à
jeanne d'arc ne doivent pas être
attribué seulement à jeanne d'arc
il procède également les chefs
militaires recrutés par charles vii
mais jeanne d'arc a eu un rôle
charismatique un rôle de meneuse
d'hommes en quelque sorte qui a
véritablement enflammé le courage et le
la vaillance des soldats français des
vassaux des villes et même un bûcher
celui de bretagne rejoignent la bannière
du dauphin et l'étendard de jeanne
la logique veut maintenant que l'on
s'attaque aux places que l'ennemi tient
autour d'orléans au nombre de trois ces
places tombent l'une après l'autre
entre le 12 et le 17 juin la levée du
siège d'orléans initie une série de
victoires d'abord la libération des
places de la loire comme meung-sur-loire
beaugency et jargeau puis c'est la
grande bataille rangée de patay les
anglais n'ont pas le temps de se
réorganiser après cette série de sièges
jane va livrer sa première bataille
rangée une bataille en bonne et due
forme est révélatrice du choix de dieu
entre orléans et paris le 18 juin
la bataille de patay lave l'affront de
crécy de poitiers d'azincourt
malgré son étendard jeanne est à
l'arrière-garde mais c'est bien poussé
par l'euphorie contagieuse accumulés
depuis orléans que les victoires sont
françaises cent fois plus de morts
anglais quel que soit le chiffre dieu et
du côté des français patey et pour
jeanne d'arc
un triomphe qui doit conduire le dauphin
au sacre
or la route qui mène à reims et
territoire bourguignon devant les
hésitations de charles ix la prudence de
ses conseillers jeanne cherche le
réconfort en dormant à la belle étoile
pendant deux nuits
le gros des troupes est de son côté on
finit par répondre à l'appel de l'armée
qui veut être celle du sacre charles à
la clairvoyance de promettre l'anis ti à
toutes les villes qui avaient oublié
qu'elle était française
après auxerre le 3 juillet ces trois une
semaine plus tard qu'ils acceptent de
reconnaître ses erreurs tout un symbole
pour la ville du traité de 14 120 rue
encore psychologie et persuasion et
conviction de shanda 3 3 était une place
forte solide et bien elle va voir le
gouverneur de la place forte de 3 en lui
disant écoutez ça risque on va mettre 3
feu et à sang on va envahir la ville
alors que on peut passer paisiblement si
vous nous accordez si vous nous héberger
quelques temps et le gouverneur qui
préférait que la ville ne fut pas piller
va en effet céder aux injonctions de la
petite jeanne d'arc et ensuite direction
reims et la semaine suivante le 17
juillet 14 129 le dauphin devient
définitivement charles 7 les valois
auront leur dynastie grâce à chan il
semble que le peuple rassemblés sur le
parvis de la cathédrale de reims
acclament davantage jeanne la pucelle
que charleroi
voilà pour le spirituel mais pour le
temporel reste une capitale à
reconquérir
or la guerre civile n'est toujours pas
terminée paris est toujours sous
influence bourguignonne et bedford a eu
le temps de réorganiser la défense de la
ville tandis que jeune veut s'appuyer
sur la dynamique actuelle
charles vii privilégie la négociation
avec philippe lebon avant de vaincre
définitivement les anglais durant le
mois d'août malgré la division l'armée
du sacre progresse tout de même sous
l'impulsion des partisans de l'accident
compiègne puis saint denis ville symbole
avec sa nécropole des rois de france et
à partir de laquelle il est tentant de
donner l'assaut c'est chose faite sous
l'impulsion de jeanne le 8 septembre à
midi jour anniversaire de la vierge
les assaillants essuie le feu de
l'artillerie parisienne la taxe poursuit
jusqu'au soir mais c'est un échec
j'en ai blessé son porte étendard tuées
portant elle veut reprendre les
hostilités alors que l'armée du sacré
déjà des visées charles 7la démobilise
totalement le 21 septembre tels que
charles septe à l'origine est surnommé
l'indolent bon il finira sa carrière en
étant sûr nommé charles vii le
victorieux mais pour l'instant c'est
l'indolent il hésite il tergiverse et
puis cette jeune femme l'inquiète un peu
il se dit tous mes officiers sont
impressionnés donc il la libère il
négocie une trêve avec philippe leuba la
dynamique est cassée
pas de miracle
la nouvelle carte géopolitique souligne
clairement que les nouvelles frontières
du royaume ont besoin d'un nettoyage
jeanne qui a du mal à supporter
l'inaction se voit confié durant
l'automne cette mission pour laquelle
elle a toujours pas de commandement
effectif
jeanne d'arc après le couronnement de
deux chars le 7 va officiellement perdre
son commandement le commandement des
troupes mais elles continuent elles
toujours avec eux d'une petite milice à
la fin de l'automne c'est un nouvel
échec à la charité-sur-loire tenus par
des mercenaires sans manières sans foi
ni loi
ils n'ont pas peur de la réputation du
chan il va bien falloir se reposer en
décembre charles vii en profite pour
anoblir jeanne et sa famille est exempté
domrémy de tact cela sera valable
jusqu'en 1789
l'hiver est long pour jeanne et déco
printemps philippe lebon semble entamer
inoffensive
elle repart en campagne sans l'accord de
chars le 7 une des cibles du duc de
bourgogne et compiègne que charles vii
lui a cédé lors des négociations de
l'automne les habitants refusent de se
soumettre
c'est en voulant porter secours à ses
fidèles sujets que jane est capturé par
les bourguignons le 23 mai 14h30
elle a 18 ans elle qui a tant besoin
d'action et de grand air
on est dorénavant privé
les discussions débutent des anglais
négocié la rançon en s'appuyant sur des
arguments religieux souffrit par des
théologiens de l'université de paris
pour lesquels janet hors norme elle est
retenue prisonnière des bourguignons
pendant quatre mois
charles vii ne tente rien pour la
récupérer en octobre il est trop tard la
somme exigée y ont été rassemblés jeanne
est transféré à rouen où il doit être
jugé pour crime en matière de foi
même s'il n'y a pas d'agent secret à ce
moment là on sait que le roi charles vii
espère entre compiègne et rouen faire
envoyer quelques troupes pour faire un
coup de force pour récupérer la petite
jeanne d'arc
si bien que les anglais vont passer par
des chemins détournés vont remonter vers
la manche vers le crotoy on arrivait à
eux et ensuite redescendre sur roy et à
ce moment là
charles n'intervient plus jane va être
jugé à rouen par le prisme ans célèbre
évêque cochon l'évêque de bové et de
lisieux et charles vii n'intervient pas
parce que il se dit si je prends trop
sans doute se dit il sa position pour
jeanne d'arc
je serai mal placé pour négocier ensuite
avec les anglais les anglais la
remettent à la justice ecclésiastique et
à partir de là les juger juger pourquoi
parce que c'est toute une histoire
jeanne d'arc elle a fait peur à tout le
monde
notamment à tous les adversaires de
charles vii est là elle a dit qu'elle
avait entendu des voix est là elle a été
dans une relation directe avec le
seigneur c'est ce que les les
ecclésiastiques ont du mal à admettre
même si dans un premier temps il avait
vu en elle une incarnation de la pureté
ça correspondait à de vieilles
prédictions disant qu'une une vierge
s'ouvre et le royaume
le procès débute en février 14 131 le
tribunal réuni se compose de 42 membres
les premières séances sont publiques les
réponses de jeanne sont parfois
maladroite parce que ça sert mais sont
toujours pleines de bon sens si on les
remet dans leur contexte
jeanne a fait ce qui lui semblait
nécessaire pour que le royaume de france
ne connaissent plus la misère qu'il
connaît depuis cent ans la petite jeanne
qui je voulais 17 à peine lire et écrire
ne n'a tout de même pas sa langue dans
sa poche et pendant son procès par
exemple quand l'évêque cauchon lui
jamais ce que quand vous l'avez vu saint
michel était bien habillé
elle lui répond du tac au tac vous
croyez que dieu n'a pas les moyens de
lever tirs l'évêque cauchon lui dsk est
ce que votre dieu aime les anglais et
jeanne lui répond mais oui il aime les
anglais mais quand ils sont chez eux
donc elles leur tient tête et plusieurs
volumes qui raconte le procès mais les
paroles de jeanne d'arc sont toujours un
peu déformé parce qu on les reprend dans
la forme juridique
elle a vraisemblablement c'était
quelqu'un de très simple elle n'a pas
parlé
le langage châtié compliqué qu'on lui
prête dans les comptes rendus de son
procès en mars
les sessions cesse d'être public les
interrogatoires se poursuivent dans sa
cellule avec un nombre restreint de
juges des soixante dix chefs
d'accusation réunis contre elle et
conserver une liste de douze lui
reprocher non plus d'être une sorcière
mais d'être à la limite de l'hérésie en
portant des habits d'homme et en se
réclamant guidés par des voies d'essence
divine pour la plupart des théologiens
il est nécessaire de s'en remettre au
pape
or le temps presse pour les anglais il
est crucial de mettre un terme à
l'histoire de cette puce elle qui sème
le doute dans leurs rangs le processus
s'accélère avec l'aide de l'université
de paris xi jeanne ne se soumet pas
l'église ne peut rien pour elle elle
sera confiée à la justice anglaise
le 24 mai une mise en scène l'attend
dans un des cimetières de rouen devant
une foule de plusieurs milliers de
personnes
on lui somme de renoncer à ses croyances
et à ces pratiques si elle n'accepte pas
elle sait que c'est le bûcher qui
l'attend peut-être est-il déjà préparé
il y avait tout tout tout s'est tu
tout ce basculement entre personnes qui
est monté porté au pinacle et puis tout
d'un coup parce qu elle est prisonnière
d'un dieu n'a pas finalement elle n'a
pas de lien avec le ciel et comme disait
l'historien jacques le goff
elle avait perdu son charisme hors
jeanne devait être inhumé en chrétienne
est la mesure airs 30 des habits de
femme habillée en femme dans sa tour à
rosas tour du prisonnier la tour jeanne
d'arc et bien les soldats anglais vont
essayer de la violente est tout
simplement si bien qu'elle va se
rhabiller en sommes à ce moment-là
l'évêque cauchon la condamnant luisant
voilà vous êtes revenu vous êtes parjure
vous êtes relapse
vous êtes hérétiques et relapse vous
êtes une sorcière le 30 mai 14 131 sur
la place du marché de rouen
jeanne est brûlée vive elle n'a pas 20
ans on va là brûlée vive comme les
sorcières parce que généralement les
gens que l'on brûlé sur le bûcher on les
égorger avant et ont léché sur le bûcher
déjà mort mais là on sépare le
confesseur martin advenu qu'elle était
bien vive sur le bûcher et que la priait
dieu jusqu'à la dernière extrémité
à peine sorti de l'adolescence illettrés
cette femme pris son destin en main et
remis en cause en deux années un ordre
établi depuis des siècles
c'est en cela que jeanne et moderne les
voix qu'elle entendait si elle nous
ramène tout d'abord au moyen-âge sont un
fait historique qui a fait prendre à la
guerre de cent ans
un virage déterminant
la position de philippe lebon a été
terriblement fragilisé depuis
l'intervention de jeanne et la politique
diplomatique patiente de charles cette
porte ses fruits
elle lui permet de réorganiser les
finances et une armée qui devient
permanente
en quatorze 135 il regrette publiquement
la mort de jean sans peur et signe avec
son fils le traité d'arras la guerre
civile débutée en 14 ans était terminée
c'est la fin de l'alliance anglo
bourguignonne et un changement radical
dans les rapports de force
à paris le nom de charles vii ne fait
plus penser aux armagnacs et même les
pros bourguignon le considèrent
maintenant roi des français c'est dunois
lebastard d'orléans qui entre le premier
dans paris provoquant la déroute des
anglais en 14 137 charles c'est très
intègre une capitale qu'il avait dû fuir
19 ans plus tôt
il faut encore quatre ans pour conquérir
intégralement l'ile-de-france le temps
de réorganiser et de stabiliser cette
nouvelle situation
charles vii s'attaque ensuite à la
normandie et au littoral aquitain
ans de bataille fort min en 14,150
castillon en 14 253 l'artillerie
française fait oublier un siècles
d'humiliation en broyant les archers
anglais seul calais reste anglaise la
guerre de cent ans s'est poursuivie bien
au delà de la mort de jeanne d'arc
l'épopée johanniques a été très courte
elle a duré à peu près deux ans et elle
s'est achevé par la mort de jeanne d'arc
en 1431 donc après la mort de jeanne
d'arc le roi de france a mis plus de
vingt ans pour reconquérir le reste du
royaume de france et notamment pour
rentrer à rouen qui est le lieu où
jeanne d'arc a été nommé quand charles 7
va finir par mourir pour laisser la
place à son fils le dauphin lyon bien
lyon va hériter me un royaume qui n'est
pas en mauvais état du tout parce que
l'intégrité territoriale et est belle
il a réussi à la bhl a vraiment à avoir
des frontières intéressante
ensuite il l'a créé des manières de
parlement il a créé une monnaie qui est
assez saine le pays est devenu un pays
en voie de modernité et son fils louis
11 achèvera précisément d'en faire une
puissance moderne en 14 156 charles se
décide enfin à faire un geste pour la
mémoire de jeanne un deuxième procès
afin de la
lité les témoignages émus de celles et
ceux qui l'ont connu se succèdent à
commencer par sa mère qui s'adresse
directement au pape
celui-ci annulera le jugement prononcé à
rouen 25 ans auparavant
il faut quand même montré un peu de
reconnaissance parce qu'autrement c'est
l'image de charles vii qui sera altérée
on dira que une reconnaît pas celle qui
l'a fait roi
on va requérir au nez refaire un procès
et puis jeanne sera en effet blanchi de
tout soupçon mais il faudra attendre la
fin du 19ème et le 20ème pour qu'elle
puisse monter sur les hôtels et devenir
la patronne de la française jeanne d'arc
un troisième procès celui de la
canonisation fait de jeunes une sainte
nous sommes en 1920 et toutes les
églises de france lui font alors une
place au milieu d'autres icônes qu'elle
adorait
jeanne d'arc est devenue sainte très
tard on aurait pu imaginer qu'elle soit
canonisé dès le xvème siècle mais ça ne
pouvait pas être le cas dans la mesure
où elles avaient été condamnées par
l'église en 14 131
même si elle a été réhabilitée en 14 156
l'église n'aime pas revenir sur ces
jugements et par conséquent il a fallu
attendre la fin du 19e siècle pour que
sa cause soit introduite auprès du saint
siège et simplement 1920 pour qu'elle
soit canonisé
le royaume n'est plus il est devenu
république et s'accorde désormais au
féminin comme la nation
quand une nation connaît une période de
progrès c'est qu'elle se fédèrent autour
de valeurs incarnées par de grands
personnages pour l'angleterre
ce fut un roi henry 5 pour la france
ce fut une paysanne jeanne d'arc tous
deux l'épée à la main est convaincu que
dieu était à leurs côtés ont su
atteindre un certain nombre d'objectifs
sont jamais atteindre l'idéal reste
leurs héritages respectifs que chacune
de leurs nations contribue à rapprocher
de cet idéal en cela charles s'est tu
n'a pas trahi jeanne en raison de son
rôle pendant la guerre de cent ans et
notamment lors de la bataille d'orléans
également parce qu'elle a été brûlé par
les anglais le personnage de jeanne
d'arc a été utilisés par la suite pour
stigmatiser l'église par exemple pendant
la période anticlérical autour de 1905
mais également pour stigmatiser les
onglets par le gouvernement de vichy en
jeanne d'arc est devenu l'image de la
résistance en quelque sorte car la
résistance qu'elle soit la résistance
des campagnes où qu'elle soit la
résistance des cités mais c'est l'image
de résistance et et juste après la
première guerre mondiale quand il a
fallu précisément redorer le blason
français
et bien c'est jeanne d'arc qui a été
choisi
à une autre époque le 15 juin 1940 le
gouvernement britannique et les
représentants de la france qu'on allait
appeler libre se mettent d'accord à
londres sur un texte permettant
d'organiser la résistance au nazisme
ce texte souligne que dorénavant la
france et la grande bretagne ne sont
plus qu'une seule nation que tous les
citoyens français sont citoyens
britanniques et que tous les sujets de
sa majesté bénéficie de la citoyenneté
française